Kokkevis:
...an engineer at Google.
I'm also the tech lead
of the O3D team
and I'm going to be giving
this presentation today
with Gregg Tavares,
who's a lead engineer
on the project as well
on API Google.
But I was wondering,
before we start,
if I could get
with a show of hands--
how many of you have
actually downloaded
and sort of
looked around O3D?
Okay.
There's a few people.
Can I ask you
how many of you
have actually done
any graphics programming
with stuff like D3D
or OpenGL?
All right, a lot more.
Excellent.
All right.
Cool.
So we kind of figured
that it would be
a pretty diverse audience.
So what we did is we--
we split the presentation
in two parts, really.
So I'm going to start
with an overview of O3D.
I'm going to give you
sort of a high-level view
of what the API is,
and what the goals were
in designing that API,
and focus on a few
different sort of areas
that we think were
sort of unique about O3D.
And in the second part,
Gregg will take over
and we'll actually show you how,
in about 20 minutes,
you can make
a little game application.
So that--that should be fun.
And...
hopefully it will be good
for you guys too.
So...O3D.
O3D, as you probably know,
is a JavaScript API for
doing GPU accelerated graphics
inside--
inside a web page.
Right now,
O3D is a plugin for--
oh, was I talking
without slides? Okay.
[chuckles]
O3D is a plugin
for all major browsers,
including IE, by the way,
so...and runs in all
major operating systems.
Right now, like I said,
it's a plugin,
but we're hoping
that it will be integrated
more closely inside the browser
starting with Chrome in first.
What kind of applications
you can run with O3D--
it's really entirely
up to you guys.
If you go
to our website,
you're gonna see a few samples
of applications--
things that we thought were
sort of interesting to do in 3D.
You know,
the obvious ones are games.
Data visualization
is another type.
You know, the--
sort of the type of,
you know, Google Earth,
displaying data on a map,
stuff like that.
Other sort of 3D scenes
and modeling sort of tools
and tools that allow you to
sort of spin around 3D models--
you know,
these are obvious examples.
But--but in reality,
you know,
any application that you
can currently do natively
with 3D graphics
you can probably do with O3D
and run it inside your browser.
Before we go into details
with the API,
I think it would be a good idea
to sort of tell you
a little bit about
the goals that we had
when we were designing
the API.
The first goal is
we wanted something
that's--that's
really expressive,
so we were really sort of--
we wanted...
the idea behind O3D
was it needed to be an API
that would be capable of doing
sort of complex rendering.
And if you think of complex
rendering, 3D rendering,
your mind typically goes
into video games.
So video games
are sort of--
probably the most complex
3D apps that you find today.
So we wanted
to design an API
that's capable of handling
that level of complexity.
We wanted something
that you can create
really sort of complex
rendering worlds,
multi-pass effects,
you know,
doing reflections,
nice shaders
in your objects,
stuff like that.
We know that we're running
inside a browser
so performance
is a major concern--
was a major concern for us.
So we made--
we took several steps
to make sure that our API is
really performing
for cases where you have
really large scenes
with a lot of objects--
which are, you know,
typically hard to do
in an environment
like the browser.
The second goal
that we had
was--was we wanted to make
an API that's really flexible.
We really didn't want
to make any assumptions
that we're making an API
specifically for making games
or for making other types
of applications.
We really wanted
a fairly low-level API
that would allow you to do
pretty much anything
you wanted to do with
3D graphics in the browser.
And finally, we're really
big believers
in the--
in the "one web" idea.
We wanted, really,
the applications that you write
to be able to run
exactly the same way,
if possible,
on all browsers
or operating systems.
This is both for the benefit
of the developers--
so you as a developer can
just sit down on your machine
and write--
write an application
and sort of be sure
that it's going to run
on everybody else's machine
and they're going to have
the same experience
as you're having
when you're looking at it.
But also from
the user's perspective--
in that, you know,
when you go to a website
that has O3D content
you want to be sure
that it actually works.
The way we did that is we--
we sort of decided
early on in a spec
of graphics hardware
that we decided to support--
and we said whatever--
whatever is capable of running
on that hardware is good
and it's going to run
GPU accelerated.
Everything below that,
we have a fallback plan
which is going to be
running itself to render.
But regardless of the case,
you're actually going to see
the same images
rendering in your browser.
Having said that,
it's--this is a list
of a few of the
sort of feature highlights.
Obviously the API
is fairly big,
and there's a lot of features.
But these are features that
are important to remember.
First of all,
like I said,
we wanted to provide
a very flexible API.
So we really give you
very--fairly low-level access
to the graphics hardware.
So we allow you to write
your own shader programs
using HLSL and Cg
as the shading language,
which gives you,
really, full access
to modern graphics hardware.
We also have the API
in such a way
that you can--you can do
modern rendering effects
like multi-pass rendering.
For example,
you can render an entire scene
in--into an offscreen buffer,
and then take that buffer
and use it for something else.
And this allows you to do
more complex effects,
like if you wanted
to do motion blurs,
depth of field effects,
stuff like that.
So this is all possible
with the API.
We give you full control
over the render states
so you have, you know,
very fine-grain control
over how you do blending,
things like that.
We also expose image loaders
beyond what the browser
actually supports.
So we load a few
compressed formats
that support levels
of detail as well.
You can load them
directly in O3D.
And I think that we've
implemented within O3D--
which is sort of--
escapes a little bit
from the--from
the typical rendering
side of things--
is we added
a fairly low-level animation
and skinning system
which would allow you
to do animated characters
within your application
fairly easily.
You can author them
somewhere else
and have them exported
and have them running
in O3D
with very little effort.
And this is something
that we wanted to do
natively inside
the actual plugin
because we thought and--
well, we still believe
that JavaScript is probably
still not fast enough
to do some of these things
that are necessary,
some of the calculations
that are necessary for that.
We know that
different browsers
have different performance
in terms of JavaScript.
So while JavaScript
is generally getting faster
in old browsers,
there's still a big disconnect
between various
browser implementations.
So--and we realized that
fairly early on.
So what we ended up doing
is we--we actually embedded
Chrome's V8 engine,
which is one of the fastest
JavaScript engines around,
within the O3D plugin--
which means that
you can select
whether you want to run
your code
inside
the embedded V8 engine--
so you're going to get
the same performance
on the same PC regardless
of the browser you're running--
or whether
you want to run it
inside the browser's
JavaScript engine.
So you have this option to do.
And finally...
we also opened an API
that allows you to--
to import assets,
3D assets,
in the browser.
That's based on JSON.
I'm going to say
a little bit more about that
pretty soon.
So...really quickly,
just to give you
an idea about APIs,
typically graphics APIs fall
into one of two categories:
there's
immediate mode APIs,
in which graphics commands
are executed sort of immediately
as you--
as you enter them,
and--and...
the side effect
of immediate mode APIs
is that if you have a frame
and you want to sort of change
something inside the frame,
you really need to redraw
the entire frame.
So you're going
to need to draw
everything
that's in the frame.
Typical examples
of immediate mode APIs
are, you know,
Direct3D and OpenGL,
which are the low-level APIs
that are used
for rendering natively.
But also if you think
in the HTML world,
the Canvas--
the Canvas 2D surface
is an immediate mode API.
On the other side
of the spectrum,
you have retained mode APIs,
where instead of actually
issuing the draw commands
one after the other,
you actually describe,
first,
the objects that
you want to render.
There's typically some sort
of a scene graph structure
that's associated there.
And there,
the high-level information
is retained between frames,
which means that the actual
system can redraw your frames
without you having
to execute code--
adding on the code
that you need
in order to sort of
make whatever changes
you need to make
from one frame to the next.
And typical examples
of that are, you know,
most game engines fall in
the retained mode API category.
In the HTML world,
SVG is a retained mode API.
And, you know, the entire
sort of HTML DOM--
you can think of it
as a retained mode API
where you describe
the page contents first
and the browser knows how
to render the entire page.
And to make this
a little bit more concrete,
imagine you have this example
where you, you know,
you have
the very simple scene.
You have, you know, red sphere
that you wanted to move
to the right
over time
and a green square
that stays constant.
If you were to use
immediate mode,
what you would
have to do mostly is,
in every frame, you would have
to execute commands
to draw everything--the
contents of the entire scene.
So you have to clear it,
move your cursor
to position,
set your color,
draw the circle,
then move to
a different position,
set the new color to green,
draw a square,
and repeat that process
for every frame.
Now, if you look at
the retained mode API,
the process
is a little simpler.
So a lot of the code
actually moves
to the initialization step
in which you create
some higher-level constructs
where you say,
"I have a circle that's red
"then a square that's green.
"I know that the square
is not going to move anywhere
so I'm going to set it
in a specific position."
And then all you have to do
each frame
is actually move the circle,
set the new position
of the circle,
and--and repeat that.
And the actual system
will be able to redraw itself.
Why this is important--
the difference between
these two approaches--
is that the stuff that
you see in the green box
is actually stuff that would
be running in JavaScript.
So if you were running
at a really fast frame rate--
say 60 frames a second,
which is sort of
a common frame rate
for an interactive
application--
you have 16 milliseconds
to issue all these--
all these draw calls.
Imagine a scene
that has, you know,
hundreds and hundreds
of objects.
It's going to be hard to
actually execute all that code
and still have time
to do your application logic.
So in some cases
retained mode API
is advantageous
in terms of performance.
So--so where does
O3D fall in?
It's--O3D is really
a low-level retained mode API.
That's the way
we want to think of it.
It has a lot
of the flexibility
of immediate mode API,
but a lot of the performance
critical aspects of rendering,
like z-sort
and forgetting transparency--
so the transparency
correcting,
doing culling, animation,
all that--
are executed
in native code.
And if you look
at the spectrum of APIs,
if you look at the far left,
there's OpenGL and D3D,
which is definitely sort of
the lowest level API
that you see.
O3D really falls
very close to that
as opposed to the other end
of the spectrum
where you have the game engines
that are super high-level.
And sort of
somewhere in the middle
but more towards
the right side
is the full-fledged
scene graphs like...
stuff that you see, like,
say the Ogre API,
stuff like that...
that definitely
have a lot more
sort of higher-level
features that--
collision detection,
potentially physics,
stuff like that.
O3D is definitely
a lot more low-level.
Stuff that you see in O3D,
like I mentioned before,
typically a retained mode API
has some sort of hierarchy.
You're going to see in O3D
two types of graphs:
You're going to see
the transform graph,
which is sort of
a typical graph
that you see
in scene graphs,
where you have
a bunch of, you know,
transforms
that describe the--
where the--where your objects
get rendered
and also the--the shapes
which are the actual mashups
that get rendered.
The shapes in our world,
because we are
fully shader based,
they get associated
with materials and effects
that contain
the shader code.
But--but this is a pretty,
you know, common structure
that you see
in scene graph APIs.
What is a bit novel
about O3D
is a different type
of graph that we have
which is called a rendergraph.
And the rendergraph
is really the recipe
for drawing 3D objects.
Like I said before,
we wanted to allow
a more complicated effect,
like doing multi-pass rendering,
stuff like that.
That--in order to describe
that kind of rendering,
we needed a different
data structure
from the data structure that
actually holds the objects.
And if you look at this,
this is just an example
of a typical rendergraph
that has both trans--
transparent and opaque pass.
But typically
what O3D will do
is it will parse this--
will traverse this graph
from sort of top to bottom,
left to right,
and will issue
rendering commands,
you know,
based on the node.
I'm not going
to go into detail
about what
really happens in there,
but I thought
that will give you an idea
of what you'll find
in a rendergraph
because Gregg is going
to mention rendergraphs
a little bit later on
in his part.
So as far as the experience
with programming with O3D,
the actual API is a fairly
low-level 3D graphics API.
So you'll definitely do a lot
better programming with O3D
if you have some experience
with 3D graphics APIs
like OpenGL and Direct3D.
In order to make things
a little simpler
for those of you
who don't necessarily
have that experience,
we've provided
a fairly comprehensive set
of JavaScript
utility libraries
that do certain things
a lot easier.
So with a one--single call,
you can create common perimeters
like cubes, figures,
you know, cylinders,
like that.
You can create
simple particle effects.
You can create shaders.
You can load--
you can stream in files
with assets,
things like that.
The utilities are not really
part of the API
but are there
to make your job easier.
And also,
they serve as very--
very good sort of sample code.
So you can use them,
you can change them
to fit your needs
if they don't fit your needs.
Finally, we expect that,
over time,
there's going to be
higher-level libraries
that will be developed
on top of all that
that will make the task
of writing O3D applications
a lot easier for
more developers, actually.
So having said all that,
you know, an O3D application
typically breaks down
into two things:
There's the code,
which is sort of--
sets up all the rendering.
It contains sort of
the application logic
and you see a lot of code
in the second part
of this presentation.
And then there's
the asset part,
which is really
all the 3D assets that you need
in order to render texture,
shaders, animation,
stuff like that.
And while
we're on this topic,
I thought I'd say
something about assets.
So--so with O3D,
we decided to not invent
yet another file format.
There's tons of file formats
for 3D stuff.
Unfortunately,
none of them really...
we thought, was a particularly
good fit for O3D.
So what we did is we decided not
to create yet another format,
'cause at this point,
like I said,
we wanted to--this format
to be very flexible
in the sense that
we don't really know
what kind of application
you're creating.
So we don't want
to create a file format
that sort of
describes something
that we don't know about.
But what we did is
we created an API
that allows you
to load in the browser
these zipped archive files.
And these
zipped archive files
can contain, you know,
generally three different types
of files.
They can contain text files.
They can contain
image files
and binary objects,
binary buffer files.
Yeah, a typical application--
for example,
if you have sort of a general
sort of rendering task
that you wanted to bring
in a whole scene,
you would probably describe
the contents of the scene
in JSON format and
store that in a text file.
You would put all your textures
in image files
inside the same--
the same archive.
And finally,
all the heavy data,
like, for example...
vertex buffers, index buffers,
animation, all that
would go into binary buffers.
So once you zip all that--
and that's a process
that you do offline--
the application requests
that file from the server,
the server sends it,
and streams it, actually,
and then the application
can extract the data
from the file
and can then
start calling
the regular O3D--O3D calls
in order to actually
create the objects.
And this is a fairly--
we found that this is
a fairly flexible approach
to--to transferring
any kind of data you want.
But, you know,
having said that,
this is a bit abstract.
In reality, a lot of
the 3D applications
really, you know,
require, you know,
general models with
textures and all that.
And in order
to give you a leg up
in that process,
we decided to write...
really a sample,
which is a converter
that takes a Collada file,
which is an XML representation
of a 3D world.
Collada files
can be exported
from most of
the DCC tools today,
like, Maya, Max...
Google SketchUp.
So you use the exporter
from the DCC tool
in order to create
a Collada file.
Then you use
the O3D converter--
[microphone cuts out]
Okay?
Cool.
[audience chuckles]
Hello?
Okay. Cool.
So we have we have a tool
that shapes with the O3D SDK
that really is a converter.
It takes a Collada file
and zips, you know,
converts all the contents
to this zip archived format
that I talked about
right before.
And then, at the same time,
we have a sample library,
a JavaScript library,
that is able to load this file
and create the O3D content
that you have.
So if you look into
the O3D SDK,
you're gonna find--
you're gonna find this tool.
And actually,
in Gregg's part--
which is about
to start right now--
he's going to be
making use of this...
to load content
in the application.
Tavares:
[inaudible]
Switch...
[indistinct chatter]
There?
Up higher?
Hello?
Testing. Okay.
So we're going to go over
making an O3D application.
This is just kind of
a small, sample start of a game.
It's not, like,
a really cool game.
But we'll go over
all the steps,
and hopefully a few days
after the show
we'll be able
to put them online.
A few things we'll probably
have to fix, but...
they are here live.
So the first thing
you have to do
is, like they said, the O3D
runs in a web page.
So you need to set up
a web page.
So normally you would
have a few script tags.
In our case,
we have our sample library.
We include this script
called base.js
and that kind of gives us
an include facility
for including
other modules.
And you can see here
where we're requiring
the module util
and the module math.
Then you have your body.
And you see we have the onload
set to call an init function.
And then,
because it's a plugin,
normally it would run
as an object tag.
But object tags
are kind of iffy in the sense
that different browsers
implement them different ways.
So you can still do that
if you want,
but our utility library
instead looks for divs
that have an I.D.
that starts with O3D,
and it will insert
inside that div an object tag.
And it will, you know,
scale to the size of that div--
happens to be.
So if you look at the next code,
here's the init function
that that onload
was going to call.
And it's going to call
this utility function
called makeClients.
It's an asynchronous function
that, again,
has to do with
being cross-browser.
Certain browsers
don't necessarily
create the objects
the moment you ask for them.
You have to keep pulling
until they
actually have created them.
So when
it's finally figured out
that it's created
those objects,
then it will call the function
that you've passed there--
in this case, initstep2.
initstep2 gets passed through
the list of all the el--
the objects
that got created.
In this case,
we only created one,
so we know we're just gonna
pull that out of that array.
And then we pull out
some globals here.
The math is
our math library.
That's just to make
our typing shorter.
The client
is the based object,
the object that
all the APIs start from.
Then we create
this thing called a pack.
A pack is something
that manages
the lifetime of objects.
And it's kind of hard
to go into the details
but the basic way
to describe it
is that all objects
are reference counted
and the pack holds one count.
So if you remove
something in pack,
it loses that count of--
nothing else is referencing it
and it'll finally
get deleted.
The next thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna create
a transform
for the transform graph
and this is--we're--
gonna be our root transform.
So everything from that and
below is gonna get rendered.
And then we're gonna call
this utility function
that will set up
a rendergraph--
basically, the rendergraph
you saw in the slide
a few moments ago.
Of course you could
create it by hand,
but it turns out
that for the--
most of the cases
we have come up,
this one routine
will create a rendergraph
that handles
most of our cases.
It passes back
this object called a--
that we store
in this function called--
or this variable
called g_viewInfo
that we'll reference later.
And you can see
we're passing in g_root,
which says this is
the part that we want to render.
And the bottom where it says
g_client_renderGraphRoot
is just attaching it
to the client's root
so that it will actually
traverse this rendergraph
for us.
Then we need to make a--
set up a camera.
We don't really have
something called a camera
but we have view
and projection matrices
for those who are familiar
with GL or D3D.
So here
you can see the first--
there's--we have a function
called updateProjection.
And it's using
that viewInfo object,
looking in this thing
called a drawContext,
which is part
of the rendergraph,
and setting the projection
matrix of that
by calling
our math utility library
that has a function
that will build
a prospective matrix for you.
And then there's
an updateCamera function
that is using the look at
function from the math library
to take an eye target
and an up vector
and build a viewMatrix and
then set that into that context.
So if we step over
to the sample--
well, nothing's
going to come up yet
'cause we haven't had any--
made any content,
but this gray area
is the area
that has been created
so far.
So now we've got to put
something on the screen.
So the first step: you need
to make some materials.
Again, we're going to call
and do a utility function.
The first one--it's going to
create just a basic material
and we're going to set it
to a green color.
And we're putting that
in this variable red material.
Then we're also going to create
a checkered material.
The checkered material
is actually going to load
a shader from a file.
The first function,
createBasicMaterial,
actually generated a shader
in JavaScript.
This one's gonna load one
from a file.
And both of those
got created in this pack
and so we're gonna--
the third part of this thing
is we're gonna
call this function
createAndBindStandardParams,
which--since we
created the shaders,
we know what parameters
they need.
If you're familiar
with shaders, they--
you specify
all of these parameters
that they need
for rendering.
Since we know which ones
got created,
we're gonna--we have this
function that will give you
a JavaScript object
that has ways to access
all those parameters
in a global way.
And so this way we can set
the light and the light color
for both of those materials
with one setting here.
Then we're going to create
a plane, a ground plane.
That's the first line.
We'll create a transform
to position that in the world.
We're gonna transparent
that transform to our root,
and then we're gonna
add that plane
to that transform.
We create a cylinder.
We create another transform.
This time we're gonna store it
in a global player transform
so that we can manipulate it
easier later.
We're gonna parent that
to the world,
and we're going
to add that shape
to that transform.
And so I go over
into step two...
there we go.
We have a plane.
We have a cylinder.
Okay, so now we gotta make it
do something more interesting.
So let's let the user
move it.
So in this case, we need to
track the state of the keyboard.
And I think,
unlike most JavaScript...
programs, you're usually
going to have to--
if you're writing a game,
you want to know
when the key is held down
and when it's released.
Not just when it's pressed.
So in this case we're
going to assign some functions
to key up and key down.
And you'll see that
we actually
call into our JavaScript
labor to do that
versus kind of like
the DOM way,
which--we'd put them
on the window or on a div.
And that's mostly
because we're a plugin.
We had to do it that way.
If we ever
are not a plugin,
we'll be able to, you know,
make it the DOM way.
And then you can see
the two functions down here:
On keyDown we're just going
to use this global array
and set,
for a particular key,
whether that key
is up or down.
If the key is let up,
we'll set it--
we'll record
that it's been released.
Then we're going to add
some stuff in our--
back in our inner function
to add a render callback.
And that--that's
a JavaScript function
that will get called
every single frame,
and potentially
up to 60 hertz
or whatever your refresh rate
on your monitor is.
Most LCD monitors
are 60 hertz.
And down here, you can see
the actual function.
It gets passed to this object,
which is a renderEvent.
Out of that we're going
to pull the elapsedTime,
and the elapsedTime
is how much time
since the last renderEvent
in seconds.
So that's useful,
and I'll show why.
And then we're going
to call this function
handleMoveKeys.
And so here's
And so you can see we have
a directionX and directionZ.
That's the direction
across our ground plane.
And these keys,
it's checking--
the first column,
it's checking the cursor keys
and the second column,
it's checking ASWD,
which are pretty common
for a lot of games.
And we're setting our direction
variables over here.
And then we're just gonna add
those to the player's position.
And then before,
in the setup,
we had the player's transform.
We're gonna set
his translation to...
where it needs to be
to move around.
So if I go over
to this step,
we should now be able
to move him around.
He's moving kind of fast.
So the next step:
We're just gonna make
that frame rate independent.
So here
we're going to set up
a...a variable
for MOVE_VELOCITY
just to make it
easy to tweak.
And we're gonna say it moves
25 units per second.
And then we're gonna go into
that handleMoveKeys function
and we're gonna change that
math that we were doing
to add to the position
to use that MOVE_VELOCITY.
And before we were just
adding the direction.
And then we're gonna multiply it
by the elapsedTime.
So it'll only move
whatever percentage of a second
this frame actually handled.
And then the rest of the code
stayed the same.
And so if I go
and run step four...
it should now run
nice and smooth.
And...regardless
of what frame rate
or how the power of the machine
that the user has,
it should move at the same rate
across the field.
So the next step is we want to
move it relative to the camera.
If I go back to the demo,
you can see that
as I move it across
it's going down the grid.
But the grid is kind of
at an angle to the camera
and that's not really
good for a game.
So there's
some little math here.
I'm not really going to go
into the math,
but there's this function
computeMoveMatrixFromViewMatrix.
So before we were
computing a view matrix
in our updateCamera function,
and if we passed that matrix
to this function
it'll return a matrix
that we can use
to adjust our movement.
And so I went
into the updateCamera,
and anytime the camera's
been updated,
I'm gonna update
this MoveMatrix just to--
so I don't have
to worry about it anymore.
And then I go back
into the place
that was moving the character.
And instead
of moving him directly,
with our direction
times our velocity
times our elapsed time,
I'm gonna take that value and
multiply it by that MoveMatrix
and it's gonna give me
two values I can instead use
to move the player.
So now if I go back and--
and...
show you that example,
you'll see that the player
is now moving
perpendicular
to the camera field.
And if I move it in and out,
it's moving in and out
of the screen.
And that's kind of
more game-like.
So the next step is: Let's make
the camera follow the player.
So that's pretty simple.
Just take
the player's position,
stick it in the target,
and call updateCamera.
And then we'll put that
in a function
and we're gonna call it
every frame as well
in our onRender.
So if I go
over to that step...
now the camera's
following the player.
But you can see
it's kind of stiff.
It's not really
a good feeling.
So let's make the camera
a little more smooth.
So we'll smooth out
the camera,
and this is a trick
that a lot of video game
programmers use.
It's not quite
frame rate independent,
but it's close enough.
Basically
what we're gonna do
is instead of using
the new place
we wanted the camera
to be directly,
we're gonna store it in
a variable called newTarget
and then we're just gonna take--
call this function lerp.
And this says, "Move from
the target to the new target."
And we're only gonna take
3% of that difference.
And make that
the new target.
And so if I
go run this sample...
now the camera
will lag behind.
So I move over here,
and the camera will catch up.
Move over here,
the camera will catch up.
And that's just
a much better feeling
than before.
So let's add
a little bit of action.
Let's make the charac--
little bit more code, and
it's a little bit complicated
to explain, but...
in the first part,
there's a little variable
where we're checking
if the layout--
a user is allowed to jump.
And I'll go over that
in a moment.
But here we're checking--
that's the space bar.
32 happens to be
the key code for the space.
If we press the space,
set this flag
that we're jumping,
and set that
we can't jump again.
That's so we can't keep jumping
while we're in the air.
And then just set the player's
velocity to some value,
which we define
other--elsewhere.
And then--otherwise
when I come through here
we'll already be jumping.
And so we're gonna
take that velocity
and we're gonna
add in gravity
and you can see we're
multiplying by the elapsed time
to make it
frame rate independent.
And we're gonna
use that velocity
and add it
to its position
also by the--multiply it
by the elapsed time
to make that
frame rate independent.
And then we're checking
whether he hit the ground
just by checking
whether he hit 0.
And if he hit 0,
then we're gonna just...
force it to 0 and
tell him to stop jumping.
And then at the bottom
you can see
the reason we have
this canJump
is that we basically
don't want it
if you hold the space bar,
that the player
will just keep bouncing.
We want to make it
that you actually
have to press the space bar
to jump again.
And so that's why,
when he's finished jumping,
we don't let him jump again
until he's released
the space bar.
And then finally,
in the translate,
where we were
positioning the player,
we add it to set
the "Y" position back in.
So if I go
and do this sample...
he should now move around
and he should jump.
[chuckles]
So let's take him
to the next step.
Let's add a little bit
of effect.
Here we're gonna create
a particle emitter.
So we have, again,
our utility libraries
and we're gonna create
a particle system,
and from that system we're gonna
create a particle emitter.
We're gonna set its state
so it's an additive particle.
That means the colors add up.
We're gonna set a little
ColorRamp here.
This ColorRamp says
start at 30% opaque white
and go to 0% opaque white
or 100% transparent.
And then we have
all these parameters
that set up some particles.
So we want
to emit 30 particles.
We want them to take--
to last a 1/2 a second,
to start at size 5, and scale
to size 10 over that time.
And then there's
some funky math
down here at the bottom,
where--if we wanted to set
the parameters directly,
we could have done just like
we did those last parameters.
But this--we want
to actually set the--
the velocity of the...
of the particles
per particle.
So I'm doing
a little math here,
which is just taking
a velocity along the ground
and rotating it randomly
at 360 degrees
so they'll come out
at some random place
around his feet.
And then I actually add
a little acceleration
so they'll slow
as they come away.
And then we create
an emitter for that,
or a one-shot emitter.
And then to use it,
we just go
back into the code
there where he's jumping.
When he lands on the ground,
we trigger that effect.
So if I go and show you
this sample...
now when he jumps
there's a poof.
[chuckle]
Okay, so having, you know,
like, a checkered plane
and a--and a cylinder,
okay, programmer art.
But you've gotta add
some real art at some point.
So the next step is:
We're gonna load a character.
And so here,
back in our initStep,
we're--instead
of making the cylinder,
we deleted that code.
We're still gonna create
a transform for the player,
but this time
we're gonna create a pack
and this is mostly
for management reasons.
We don't really
have to do this,
but it make--
keeps things separated.
And then we're gonna call
this function loadScene.
And we pass in that pack
to say everything we load
to get--create from that pack,
and we're gonna pass in
that player transform
to say everything
that gets loaded,
build under that transform.
And here you can see
we passed it in a path.
And then because
this is a web API,
the whole thing
has to be asynchronous
'cause you don't know how long
it's gonna take
to download that.
And so when it's finished
we want to tell it to continue
with initStep3.
And initStep3 is
all the code we used to have
below the point
of creating the--the cylinder
plus a few extra lines,
and these few extra lines
are listed here
which is to prepare the pack.
That goes through the pack
and creates the standard shaders
that our utility library
will create for you.
If you're doing
something custom,
you might stop there and
actually create custom shaders
to do something
really fancy.
And we're gonna bind
the parameters again
from the ones
we bound before,
so that all of the shaders
that just were created